[Music]
germany's chancellor olaf schultz is in
kiev ahead of a planned trip to moscow
on tuesday it's part of a flurry of
in-person diplomacy by western leaders
who fear that russia could invade
ukraine at any time the kremlin though
deny is planning any such attack
but ukraine is demanding direct answers
from moscow about why more than one
hundred thousand russian troops have
taken up positions on its borders
let's go live down to kiev al-jazeera's
natasha butler is there for us so
germany's chancellor is there now in
kiev what can we expect from him
yes olaf schultz meeting vladimir
zelensky ukraine's president of course
to talk about the situation that berlin
has called
critical this is schultz's effort at
furthering the european diplomatic push
to try and avert a war
in europe as those concerns continue
over russia's intentions over whether or
not russia plans to invade ukraine even
though moscow continues to deny it's got
any such plans well celensky and schultz
will discuss the situation they'll also
discuss possible german plans to offer
more financial aid and assistance to
ukraine to help it's a now ailing
economy
but there have been some concerns and
frustrations amongst many uh ukrainian
officials over the fact that moscow but
over the fact i should say that berlin
still refuses uh to give any weapons to
ukraine they would like to see much more
military assistance from germany
uh charleston after his meetings there
in kiev is set to visit moscow tomorrow
tuesday and what can we expect from that
yes the german chancellor will be uh
traveling to moscow to meet the russian
president vladimir putin he is expected
to listen to russia's security concerns
that's what we understand from the
german government but he will also come
with a message that should russia choose
to uh invade ukraine that there will be
very swift and severe consequences
from western powers we could also expect
schultz and putin to discuss the north
stream 2 pipeline that pipeline that
runs
from russia to germany the u.s president
joe biden when he was meeting all that
shorts last week said that if there was
a russian invasion that pipeline
should be stopped that the gas would
never flow from russia something
obviously russia would be very concerned
about germany though has not been so
clear about its intentions so perhaps we
will hear more from schultz some say
that could be a card that germany uh
could play uh during that meeting it's
going to be much more challenging
meeting for schultz i'm seeing it as a
bit of a test for this new german
chancellor who comes in the footsteps of
angler merkel merkel a fluent russian
speaker who had many years of experience
uh with vladimir putin
i'll just there's natasha butler there
live in kiev let's go then to berlin
dominic kane is there uh
dominic what are the expectations in
berlin from
today's visit to kiev and tomorrow's
from in moscow
expectation well
of in terms of expectation
hope might be one way of looking at it
what they are hoping to
see is some effect that the chancellor
might have some ability to transform the
situation some ability to bring the two
sides together in a way which would
de-escalate things de-escalation is the
watch word that's been coming from the
german chancery from mr schultz and his
party for some considerable time now he
is trying to cast himself in the guise
of someone who can be seen as a mediator
as somebody who can as it were feel the
pain of the one side but be able to
persuade the other that perhaps
de-escalation is the way to go but
remember also that whatever the
chancellory here and indeed the entire
government here expects or hopes it has
to deal with the historical aspects that
any german government has to deal with
in so far as that part of eastern and
south eastern europe is concerned
that's why we don't see german weaponry
german munitions in the hands of the
ukrainian army and the ukrainian
government we don't see that so far
there may be some movement insofar as
certain non-lethal
forms of assistance for the ukrainian
soldiers but no weapons as yet so when
mr schatz meets president zielenski the
reassurance he hopes to give well how
reassuring will it be given we know what
germany has said its red lines are as it
were and there is in terms of
expectation it is worth making the point
that amongst the german population there
is a very real reluctance
to see german weapons in the hands of
any force whatsoever that might then go
on to use them against russian troops
al jazeera's dominic kane live in berlin
dominic many thanks right let's get the
view now from moscow as dorsa jabari
reports poland is joining the diplomatic
push
we do expect the polish foreign minister
to arrive in the russian capital later
on monday he is of course the chairman
of the osce organization and he was
scheduled to come here for a visit
um in the as of last week so
his trip will really be an important one
and possibly address the concerns that
ukraine has raised the polish foreign
minister will meet his russian
counterpart later on tuesday but it's
important to highlight that the
osce which is one of its mandates is
crisis management and arms control has
decided to withdraw its um
civilian um
monitoring mission in eastern ukraine as
a result of the security situation there
and the russian foreign ministry has
reacted to that saying that it's very
very dangerous because
that mission was really the eyes and
ears of the world about maintaining the
so-called ceasefire of the that was
agreed upon under the minsk agreement in
2015 that was supposed to have a
ceasefire ongoing in that region but
once these
this osce mission is pulled out of there
there really is nobody to monitor that
agreement and that's a cause for concern
for the russians the foreign ministry
spokesperson also said that it's very
important that this organization is not
used
as a tool in the political game of
what's happening right now
well a number of russian forces in
belarus is the largest since the end of
the cold war they're engaged in
intensive war games that nato considers
a potential prelude to an invasion al
jazeera's step faster reports now from
an airfield near the border with ukraine
at the sabrevika airfield russian
helicopter gunships take to the air
nearby dozens of russian trucks leave
the training grounds
armoured personnel carriers are
transported towards the border with
ukraine the south of belarus looks like
a russian military zone
this abandoned airfield in sabrovka near
the city of hommel is one of the 12
areas where russia and belarus are
conducting joint drills known as allied
resolve
visitors are not allowed in but local
people tell us the airstrip is in bad
shape and has recently been used for
sports competitions
footage released by the russian ministry
of defense shows state-of-the-art
military equipment in action near the
border between belarus and ukraine and
nato
several divisions of s-400 missile
defense systems and dozens of sukhoi
fighter jets are taking part in the
exercises
in response to questions from the baltic
states belarus has confirmed that
russian forces are also active outside
the scope of these drills
some military units and subunits from
the eastern military district of the
armed forces of the russian federation
are performing tasks outside the
framework of the exercise
they have been deployed and are
performing practical measures to guard a
southern state border where there are no
opportunities to reinforce it using
border patrol units of the republic of
belarus there are a lot of questions
about the exact size and the real
purpose of these exercises happening
around 20 kilometers from the border
with ukraine for sure russian forces are
a lot more active this close to the
ukrainian capital kiev a lot more active
than they've had been since the end of
the cold war but for many here it's hard
to believe that war is imminent
for people living at home now close to
the border it is difficult to find out
what's going on
it won't happen we were told it won't
happen first they said there will be a
war but i watched the news and
lukashenka said there won't be a war
they brought tanks and trucks and we
thought it was a war but it turns out it
was a test of military readiness
vladimir katsura the leader of an
opposition party in homeland is not that
optimistic he says many people in
belarus would like to demonstrate
against a possible war but are too
scared to do so
i'm personally very worried i have
family i don't want war like most
belarusians but as i see the
developments going on so far under the
disguise of military exercises it
naturally makes me very worried
on this main road to ukraine's capital
kiev buses and trucks are still crossing
the border but kiev is only 200
kilometers away and russia's show of
military force nearby is making people
in ukraine and western powers very
nervous staff farsan al jazeera in
sybrovka belarus
a palestinian teenager has been shot
dead by israeli security forces during
unrest near the city of janine in the
occupied west bank